this is based on a memoir that was
published I think about 12 years ago by
Brad land that book is obviously very
much part of his storing the things he
experienced and he was beaten there's a
goat with laxatives made a lot of the
things that happen in this movie are
representing the book has anything
changed in those 12 years have things
gotten better or worse or the things
that he is describing his memoir just as
prevalent today as they were a dozen
years ago yeah I don't think anything's
changed at all basically which is just
bizarre right I mean I I mean the fact
that it hasn't really changed in maybe a
hundred years or I don't know how long
frankly is bizarre you know I mean like
people are breaking the Geneva
Convention regularly on our on our
campuses and it just doesn't it doesn't
seem too complicated to me in terms of
like not wanting to let that happen so
yeah I mean you know hopefully this
movie but also a lot of stuff in the
news I don't know if people saw the ESPN
piece about the the Sodom izing
incidents along with other kind of
horrible hazing things that were
happening on football teams in in high
school and college all across the
country so I mean we sort of have to pay
attention to young dudes you know
there's a lot going on there there's a
very brief scene in this movie of what I
think we can call torture porn it's
graphic sex where the guy is kind of
choking the woman it's just like a
couple of second shot that you use and
the way in which this is viewed clearly
very important even though it only lasts
a second or two you talk about that
scene and why it's included and how it
fits into the bigger picture of what you
are trying to address here yeah I was
saying to outside of really glad you
noticed that shot like you know I think
in that shot was everything that that
Brad felt like he should aspire to like
he was both connecting to the darkest
part of the the male psyche or the male
inclination or whatever that is both at
both that's something that
that just tore him apart those two guys
out there those forces inside of that
and that you know paradoxically maybe
that's also what he should have had can
that's what he should if he had had some
of those you know values or abilities in
himself maybe he would have been safe
you know so I think he's almost
examining that you can see that he's
just kind of dead to it he doesn't
understand how he's supposed to relate
to or live up to that you know one of
the things that you decided very early
on is that you've worked in nonfiction
films as whereas as well as narrative
films you decide to make this a
narrative feature did you ever consider
trying to do something in this world a
documentary or does narrative give you
something that you can't do a non
fiction film yeah i mean my my company
had actually thought very seriously bit
about trying to make a fraternity doc a
couple years earlier and i we're sort of
interested in that kind of stuff and
that really it's an access problem it is
impossible to get access and the closest
that anyone's ever come really is his
frat house by todd phillips which was
his first movie and the only way that he
got in was to submit to the hazing
himself which of course presents all
kinds of controversy from a documentary
point of view but yeah I mean it's just
really hard to get in but I think the
other thing that's maybe most important
about making a movie like this and why
Brad lands story in particular was so
necessary to presenting this materials
that without the framing tale without
his trauma going into this process it
just becomes sort of a documentary where
you just watch people do horrible things
so it's it's it's the fact that he was
so damaged going into this whole thing
that allows us to kind of lens the whole
process through his experience which was
truant was just traumatic when you're
thinking about the ways in which you're
going to shoot the two I guess
centerpiece scenes of violence the
beating and the hazing they are
obviously going to exist in opposition
to each other narrative Lee a little bit
when you're thinking about how you're
going to shoot them and tone
n level of violence what are the
conversations that you have with your
with your crew with your actors about
what that balance is going to be and
what did you want it to be yeah i mean i
really think that the forces that were
alive in these people who beat him and
the forces that were alive and what
happened in the basement are very
similar forces at work and so in terms
of the actual beating we wanted it to
feel as loose and as uncontrolled as as
the hazing stuff so so we really like
when he was when he was when the when
the criminal was beating him I had the
stunt guy show him a lot of stuff that
he could just kind of keep doing himself
so I just let him keep going it wasn't
like one hit and then one thing like it
was all about this humiliation and kind
of dragging him around and like
humiliating him on some level so I
wanted those two things to be congruent
because in the end you know if if you're
poor a lot of these forces that young
men are dealing with these inclinations
are manifested in gangs and violence or
you know drug abuse or whatever it may
be and if your middle class maybe join a
frat but you don't really exorcise those
demons if you join a frat that becomes
part of you and I suspect that's why you
created the character of Mitch who
doesn't exist in the book that he is
somebody who is evidence that this is
not a phase this is becomes a way of
life is that this backstory of James
Franco's character yeah so I a couple
legacy guys from so I had friends who
went to UVM and a bunch of maroon frats
and I went to a party one night and
there was a legacy a legacy guy there
and you know he was like 40 and just
getting hammered and trying to you know
screw girls basically and it just I was
stuck with me I mean it was just like I
couldn't believe it really i mean i
guess maybe I shouldn't be laughing but
it was ridiculous and so so yeah so when
Mike and I were going to the script I
just said we should put one of these
guys
in there and then of course James was a
producer and we like well that come on
that's two too perfect so um yeah yeah
cameos are really tricky but i ended up
I I mean I think that the the scene is
well is one of the one of the great
scenes in the movie for me is that
because the actors themselves are kind
of reacting to franco's presence well
it's it's that so that's one of the
that's one of the cool things about that
scene is that the actors felt exactly
about Franco as an actor as the frat
boys would have felt about the legacy
dude Mitch like this legendary guy who
was so crazy but then the other thing
about that scene is I talked with Franco
a bunch before he went in we just talked
about the violence and I tell you talk
about the slapping and he kind of looks
like on about the slapping and i was
like aunt there's a lot of slapping like
physical dia so he goes in and i'm on
the monitor and he just walks in and
just hauls off on Brad and I was like
whoa whoa whoa cuz there wasn't supposed
to be any physical contact at wholesale
i puzzled yeah well no the punch me you
know the punch me in the face and then
punch me in the stomach but he wasn't
supposed to start hitting it okay so he
walks into the room and he just smashes
Brad across the face and I could just
see the shock on Ben's face like whoa
you know but but Ben's into it and he's
such a good actor so he just rolled with
it and everyone outside on the monitor
was like like do we stop and I was like
no no no um so that also just adds his
kind of spaten aided his scene and then
he got them revved up in this way that
felt really like you know it made the
whole thing be you know what it what it
could be I think during the hazing and a
lot of moments in this film it's
inevitable to think about movies like
Lord of the Flies but I thought about
something else and it's been turned into
a movie and that is the Stanford Prison
Experiment where are people who are cast
and rolls start behaving in those roles
that was the prison experiment on the
film itself when you have pledges and
fraternity brothers who are hazing those
pledges what did you see in behavior
that you needed for performance but that
started to scare you and
how they were treating these young men
yes that was really I should have
watched that movie before I made this
movie but i actually just actually
watched a couple months ago and i really
i really liked it and when I was
watching it I thought exactly this I
thought I on the set what was so
disturbing I think mainly to the
brothers who were doing the hazing was
how quickly they became entirely
invested and started you know having
some kind of perverse enjoyment while
they were doing it I mean I think I one
point we did a 14-minute take when they
were they had the bags over their head
and they were getting pushed in and then
when it got down into the thing we've
been going for and they just
spontaneously picked up some of the
props and started doing all that stuff
and it just turned into like a like the
chimpanzee cage at the Museum I mean it
just started going nuts you know and so
it felt like a social experiment and I
remember I called cut on that because
they could tell it was like crossing the
line and a couple of the guys came to me
after both in the basement and out in
the thing or like that that was really
disturbing you know because I just felt
like and so so for the basically it's
evidence of the fact that we are so
easily programmed that within a matter
of minutes with the right parameters we
can be turned into monsters and I think
it's something that's very important to
be aware of for all of us you know so so
the Stanford Prison Experiment
experiment applies directly to to my
experience making it and on all levels
in them in the movie I think they both
share a lot of stuff this is a large
part of the book and it's certainly a
large part of the movie and that is the
kind of homoerotic nature of eternities
that there is a huge amount of
incredibly horrible language about gay
behavior and about being gay and yet
there is a very odd juxtaposition of the
way in which these boys or young men
touch and talk to each other what do you
want to say in this film about that
seeming dilemma or paradox well I think
a lot of of homosexual hate speech is
comes out of insecurity so people are
probably
aired that they have like a little bit
of that in them i mean my belief is that
sexuality is this sliding scale and that
as animals we want to be affectionate
and that goes for young men too and they
don't know how to be affectionate so
that gets manifested in these kind of in
this kind of bizarre and sometimes
brutal behavior so it's like it's
affection masked in these violent things
that are masculine so is so what allows
them to demonstrate their their their
affection is doing it brutally you know
as a secondary issue I think men at that
age are so horny that it's just like
anything gets them off a little bit you
know I mean in whether it's in warfare
when young men you know are in the army
and also in prison obviously I mean
there's you know there's a lot of
homosexual you know relationships with
people who may not have you know just
the ratio goes way up so I think that's
also part of it they're all isolated in
that space and but I actually I think
it's a really funny paradox I can't help
thinking and so I wanted to bring that
out like I encouraged them to say you
know [ __ ] a lot because I I wanted people
to kind of like see that and then yet
feel how it was all kind of like touchy
Robbie you Thea indraneel thank you so
much thanks so much thank you guys going